there are places in the universe where
you could turn to Ash freeze to death or
be completely crushed by gravity
and you're about to visit them all
what conditions make some of these
exoplanets so dangerous
what would happen if you set foot on
them
and which planet would slash you up to
bits and pieces
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you visited the Galaxy's most
dangerous planet
Earth exists in the precious Goldilocks
zone of our solar system
that means that its orbit is within a
distance from the Sun at which liquid
water could exist on the surface
and with liquid water there's the
potential for life
and while the search continues for other
planets in the universe that could
support life there are many that are so
dangerous that you can cross them off
the list right now
but before you do why not take a death
defying journey through space to check
them out or are you too scared
before we leave for the furthest reaches
of space let's take a moment to clean up
our own home you know last month the
United States passed the inflation
reduction act this is the most
significant investment in combating
climate change in the nation's history
finally after Decades of Big Talk the
country's putting a plan into action if
they follow through America can reduce
emissions by 40 percent by 2030 and the
tax incentives for families are crucial
we're talking tax breaks up to 7 500 for
purchasing electric vehicles and
fourteen thousand dollars in Direct
Customer rebates for more energy
efficient home appliances these devices
can save you up to 350 a year and once
you own the vehicle you can take
advantage of electric vehicle tax
credits to save up to one thousand
dollars a year this is just the
beginning but now you can invest in a
Greener World while protecting your own
green hey the change begins at home with
you and with me and now a net zero
emissions economy by 2050 is more
possible than ever before so you can
make this planet much safer than the
worlds you're about to visit
peace and ABB let's start with a planet
that orbits not one but two stars and
the combined mass of this binary star
system is five to six times that of the
sun if the larger of the two stars B sen
a were placed in the center of our solar
system
it would be hot enough to melt rocks
here on Earth
luckily this exoplanet is located far
enough away to keep things cool enough
for us
what makes this planet so dangerous for
you is that it's gaseous just like
Jupiter there's no surface for you to
exist on
and the deeper you go the more it could
crush you
at 692 kilometers down into its clouds
you'd feel atmospheric pressure that's
over 1100 times stronger than Earth's
Kepler 36B
picture a super Earth with a mass of
nearly four of our home planets combined
it whips around its star in just 14 days
and is too close to be in its star's
habitable zone but
those things wouldn't be what makes it
so dangerous for you
Kepler 36B and its neighbor kepler-36c
are packed together
sometimes they're only separated by less
than five times the distance between
Earth and the Moon meaning in the night
sky you'd see this other planet towering
above you
but the proximity causes some huge
gravitational tides
so much so that they deform both planets
and the result well if you made a stop
over here you'd probably die from the
tons of Epic volcanic eruptions on the
surface
Ogle 2005 blg 390lb
this exoplanet has a mass of five and a
half Earths
it takes nine years to make one full
orbit and is located far away from the
habitable zone of its dim star
that means that it has a lot in common
with a planet a bit closer to home
Neptune
to visit this frigid World you'd need an
especially warm space suit
temperatures here would be about minus
220 degrees Celsius
that's even colder than liquid nitrogen
if you accidentally inhaled the
atmosphere here your lips would
instantly suffer cold Burns and your
cheeks and tongue would be dealing with
severe frostbite keep it up and you
could destroy the lining of your mouth
throat and Airways to your lungs
K2 141b
get ready to zip around a star every few
hours because on this exoplanet you'd
make one full orbit in just one third of
an Earth Day
that would be about every seven hours
K2 141b is almost
140 times closer to its star than Earth
is to the sun and the two are tidally
locked together
that means that one side of the planet
always faces its star
the hot side would have temperatures as
high as 3 000 degrees Celsius
and besides burning you to death this
heat creates other dangers an ocean of
magma as deep as 100 kilometers an
atmosphere of vaporized Rock and
supersonic winds with speeds up to 5 000
kilometers per hour
end on the colder side temperatures
would plummet to as low as minus 200
degrees Celsius
if you landed here you'd be exposed to
rocks raining down from the sky and
they'd hit you faster than bullets from
a gun
Ogle TR 56b
speaking of the weather this next
exoplanet would be one of the most
insane places you could ever think of
stopping by this gas giant has a mass
nearly one and a half times that of
Jupiter and yet it's located about 40
times closer to its star than Earth is
to the sun you'd arrive to find it has
an intense surface temperature of about
1725 degrees Celsius
this is so hot that iron evaporates into
clouds in the upper atmosphere
didn't check the forecast before leaving
your ship or you could just get caught
in a hot molten iron rainstorm that
would burn you alive
celt 9B
if you thought that was hot get ready to
check out one of the hottest planets
ever discovered
this tidally locked gas giant receives
44
000 times more energy from its star than
Earth gets from the Sun on the day side
temperatures could be as high as 4 315
degrees Celsius
that would make it hotter than most
stars
at that temperature even hydrogen
molecules wouldn't be able to stay
intact
you'd be a goner in less than a
millisecond on this planet
PSR
b1257 Plus 12.
pulsars are fast rotating neutron stars
that regularly emit pulses of
electromagnetic radiation
this exoplanet is a pulsar Planet so if
you land here you'd be showered in
radiation ranging from visible light to
X-rays and even gamma rays located 980
light years away in the Virgo
constellation its Pulsar star spins at
an incredible
161 times per second and it's also one
of the smallest exoplanets ever found
it may be so small that there'd be
almost no gravity to keep you in place
but it's the radiation that would be
your demise here
acute radiation sickness would kick in
within hours and you'd experience nausea
confusion and possibly lose
consciousness
stick around for up to three days and
you'll almost certainly be in a coma or
dead
hd189733b
don't let this gorgeous cobalt blue
planet fool you
this world is the deadliest planet of
them all
that color may look like an ocean but
what you'd be seeing are high clouds
full of silicate particles and these
particles would tear your body apart
the winds here are blowing at speeds of
up to 8 700 kilometers per hour that's
seven times faster than the speed of
sound and if the wind itself couldn't
kill you the glass rains certainly would
all that silicate would hit you at
thousands of kilometers an hour it would
pierce your body over and over
which is why this is nicknamed the
slasher planet
okay so maybe these dangerous places
wouldn't make for the most fun vacation
so why not explore a little more locally
first
like a day on every planet in our own
solar system
well that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]